uh i'm on a diplomatic i'm taking these
people to coruscant where are you taking
them
to coruscant
that doesn't compute
you're under arrest
okay i'm done
he asked he asked for it feel free to
drop that any time
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of idiots and abroad i'm alana
that's jacob that's rahul and that's
john no pointing today um
john
where in the world are you today
i'm in good old kansas city missouri i
tell you what you know what when i
texted you i said kansas thinking that
kansas city was in kansas many people
have that problem us missourians are
really what it's not
it's
it's a circle you know
cities are like you know they spread out
like a virus
like bacteria of course humanity is a
straight line just cut it down the
middle you sound like agent smith
yes yes
wait so half of kansas city is in
missouri and the other half's in kansas
basically yeah and people say oh they're
two different cities
yeah
technically
technically but i i wanted to go to
sprout outside to drive to kansas
[Laughter]
why did you pick the missouri side then
because uh everyone says it's cooler
and
it sounds about why you can buy liquor
on sundays
i wonder what the process for that was
like when they were drawing that state
line like oh there's a city here called
kansas city let's just go right through
the middle missouri
yeah we don't need the whole thing kind
of taking a little chunk out of it like
a lot of australian states we do have
some like really hard jagged lines but
some of them are just like
because they've tried to figure out how
to line out the maps of the borders
uh up in oakland uh i lived in a place
called north richmond which is a subset
of richmond which is a little square cut
out of richmond now richmond is one of
the best police forces they're all about
uh community
and things like that they've really been
lowering the recidivism rate of
criminals
north richmond that little square cut
out of richmond
uses the state police or the county
police whatever and it's downwind from a
shell
oil
processing facility
and so i'm pretty sure that's why the
square is cut out you go outside and it
smells like gasoline that's great oh
yeah and i like the smell of gasoline
the
like deaths and illnesses and stuff are
like so much higher in north richmond
compared to
everywhere else
north richmond forever
yeah i lived in west oakland for a while
and i used to get the train to work and
then i stopped when somebody got shot
this is roadman podcast okay that's what
i can do like
it's just it's just four dudes gone near
nah like you get me
so yeah
let them speak sprout
that's what it is
right straightforward exactly
yeah what's everybody drinking what are
you drinking jacob
i'm doing some pineapple cider oh lovely
because i finished my bottle of 19
crimes and left it on my desk john's
drinking water i'm drinking water and i
only have vodka
i don't have any mixers because i'm in
this airbnb only for a few more days oh
i will we'll get into that i am i've
decided to follow in jacob's footsteps
and i'm drinking
detective comics
thousand
wine
isn't that valuable dc probably it's
nice
it's non-alcoholic sparkling cider
what's this so it's not even alcoholic
that would be dc my friend it's just
delicious
you see
dc
oh like the comic book batman people
spiderman
oh yeah
but we like saying would you get rid of
that a it's fun batman superman
painkillers so i'm only allowed water
it sounds like a [ __ ]
actually got uh that snoop dogg wine
bottle stuck up his ass and so that's
why he's cut it right out i know that i
know that phrase cheeks
jacob's rougher than he looks
that's not saying much
jacob jacob he's jacob fuller man
nice
whole man just like mr hands
wait we have michael he wanted to uh
we asked for a hole if he wanted to
reschedule a podcast because of his pain
and he said
oh
just me
it's okay
it's no deal bravo
that's what he said i couldn't
understand what he said
that's how he talked is just the gist of
it
if anyone's wondering why i look
stoned it's not i'm not it's uh i had a
some dental work done for a couple of
days ago i wanted to get my teeth fixed
before i go off and film
um
one of the injuries we spoke about was
sustained on midnight mass
so the other day i've had two teeth
ripped out at the back here
and i had uh some bone grafting done to
my jaw here yeah
um and i've been fine but i woke up this
morning in pain um
and it's been the worst today for some
reason uh
so before we did the podcast i popped
10 penicillin
i'll pop six penicillin
two
ibuprofen
three viagra
uh
and um so now life's great okay some
jelly bean what's your flavor good job
because they said you gotta eat you
can't have your empty stomach so i mixed
it with jelly beans
you have jelly beans in your dick
jelly beans haul like a pill yeah just
in the in the same handful jelly beans
how's the erection
engorged he has to check he used to look
i can't find it
but i know i'm hard it's there somewhere
i know i'm hot i just can't see it
that's why you're faint all the blood's
gone yeah
and the
penicillin i love the idea of somebody
thinking it's it's a drug and i'm being
on it big fan the penicillins for the
venereal disease i got
oh okay won't be the first won't be the
last yeah so i heard that
what a lot of celebrities and athletes
do i'm about to g up more mandem and um
but
what they'll do is they'll tell a doctor
that they got strep throat so if they're
cheating on their wives or whatever you
know that they they're they're ganning
just skins you get me just [ __ ]
and ting for real yeah no condoms no
johnnies you get me yeah and then what
you do is yeah because you're not sure
right you ain't got time to take no like
you know test you get me for like stds
and ting right so you go up to your
doctor you go your boss man man's got
[ __ ] strep throat
and they can't really check for it so
what they do is they prescribe the
antibiotics you get me so what it does
is it clears up any knob rot you got for
real but you'd still be infectious
well
yeah no one cares about that it's as
long as you're missing giving your wife
herpes
the antibiotics took care of things no
it doesn't get rid of
herpes that said does antibiotics work
on herpes because isn't no herpes
yeah did you say knob rot yes
okay john
actually why don't we talk about
the two before we get into your road
trip adventure um why don't we talk
about your
the john jacob adventures to oakland you
guys went on
on a trip to visit sir bones i believe
where's our hotel is
it's really hard to get into because of
the experience we went through alana
no nobody's gonna laugh
nobody was at fault here so we drove up
at home
um jacob did the courtesy of driving
i did the
yeah i did the equally important
jacob jacob he's a wonderful person to
be in a calling i was trying i was doing
my darndest i was i was doing i was
doing it he was doing we swerved into
the oncoming lane like six times he kept
trying to do the roadmap video listeners
were all holding fun of the way jacob
drives jacob did his lean
um i knew john was in the car
if if there's people in the car i can't
i'm not gonna be caught dead at 11 1.
i think you should drive safe again
when jacob and i drove to vegas i
thought he was a wonderful chauffeur did
you have a good experience john
i did yeah he was a great driver um
uh and then when we got to the hotel
that i booked
which
in my defense
was not the cheapest hotel
i picked the
second cheapest hotel
and safe bet
you would think
uh clearly
uh i made a miscalculation and jacob
quick question what happened
why couldn't you get into the parking
lot
oh oh yeah it was interesting i'm sure
this happens all the time at hotels but
uh there was a tow truck blocking the
entrance of the parking lot that was
towing away uh an abandoned stolen
vehicle that was just left in the hotel
parking lot huh
just happens all the time had to wait
for a little bit not a great omen for
the rest of the hotel
yeah and not like last omen either you
picked this hotel based on like the
pictures looked all right right like
yeah okay in the pictures the pictures
looked all right yeah and that's a good
enough qualifier for a hotel alana
should i sh do like a share you the
pictures so that you can show them on
the screen capture uh yeah i mean you
could just screen share if you have them
on your pc
yeah and this is also a great lesson to
audio listen uh listeners to watch us on
youtube to watch it so you can see
that's only most people i thought you
see yeah i thought you said we don't
even have audio listening [ __ ] audio
listening
for audio listeners out there [ __ ] you
no we think you're great i'm trying my
best i'm doing my best okay we're almost
done hand gestures i can't scare my
string screen yet because there's a lot
of screenshots
there's a lot of screenshots of airsoft
fatty
why
and said it was great which like i don't
know who you think you [ __ ] are that
you think one of you pricks doesn't have
imessage and it messes with our group
chat
it's john
if y'all haven't seen this it's really
good what kind of person do you think
you are that you think that i will take
my time to click a link and watch a
youtube video based on if y'all haven't
seen this it's really good you have to
give somebody more than that for a text
it was for jacob and rahul
a long time ago did you see the
thumbnail no because it doesn't know
because it doesn't work
it's a little bit pretty cool
the whole thing was i thought it was the
thumbnail who's going to sell you one
you have to tell people if you're
sending them a link you got to sell it
hey look at the thumbnail
that doesn't make any sense
rob just so you know yeah when you're in
a when you're in a group message with
imessage users yeah yeah yeah you don't
even have to go to youtube it plays in
the [ __ ] text message chain yeah and
then you send us blank link no preview
do you remember when i tried to send and
remember when i tried to send you lot
the video of jacob saying when i watched
a gundam animation yeah and it came out
looking like it was shot on my lego
webcam yeah because of you
like a webcam that's actually quite sick
we can come back to that but right now
do you have images for us
i'm going to go i'll be back in 45 years
uh none of them loaded it's just
pictures of
what boats
okay if you want to send me a link i can
i can
whatever let's just describe it in
detail jacob what happened
after you parked okay well i parked
and we walked over to the
to the stairs well you wouldn't got the
keys which that went all right yeah that
went all right yeah they're not getting
the keys this time it went all right um
and then we proceeded up the stairs to
our room no really big red flags here we
saw the pool the pool was kind of nasty
we're like ah nobody's using it it's
because of covenant and stuff i believe
as we were walking by it you went
there's definitely a gator in there
i didn't say that
just because it looked like a swamp so
we get to our room card key yeah beeps
door opens we go inside
and um
start to notice a few things well the
first thing oh go ahead
yeah yeah
this is with me you can feel the smell
you could
you could feel the air in that place
zero airflow
and it was definitely it was a
non-smoking now but it was definitely a
smoking room for at least
like 60 years
uh for the
audio listeners reappeared with a shot
of john's face that says i'm gonna make
you calm on it that is it
you got this you forgot to wear it
didn't you you got to say it right alana
i'm on painkillers i forgot i'm going to
make you guys you mean penicillin it's
not painkillers i'm on penicillin
okay so there's a there's a dank musty
smell about cigarettes that's what it's
about
30 years of cigarettes oh like
permeating everything delicious and
we kind of we walk in slowly like oh
and there's like two light or there's
one one light yeah on a fan in the fan
ceiling fan which was oh we look at the
sheets okay i'll speed it up here we
look at the sheets
mini cigarette burns
jacob starts looking through the drawers
there's tags and everything inside of
each one
um there's an eight most tags like
graffiti like markers
oh yeah yeah yeah like cut in with the
knife the s with the three you do the
line the line the line the line the line
see that's cool though yeah classic
um okay i'm going to share my screen
um
here we go
how do i do this trip down memory lane
most disabled participants screen
sharing
um
so i'll just go over the highlights
before we show the pictures
uh ac unit
stripped of all its copper i'm pretty
sure uh missing the front vent
turn it on and it just shoots out dust
yeah it just blasts air and dust and
nothing stops it
and there's there's it's also located in
uh what i like what i thought it was
maybe a death corner or where like you
would chain
when you're hostages
um
we definitely we checked the whole bed
for all both beds for bed bugs yeah that
was our first fear is that yeah there's
gonna be bed bugs in this place
and there luckily weren't yeah how do
you know i thought they were
mythological for real they're real
i thought it's like something like you
know boogeyman and i thought you know
don't let the bed bugs by i thought that
was just a mythological
something you're thinking of dust
bunnies which are way
they
blue's clues [ __ ] me up with that [ __ ]
that's buddies what what does a bed bug
do was it blues clues what's the problem
anything so like if you stay in a hotel
that has bed bugs
and you at any point like opened your
luggage they are probably inside of your
life you have to like bring all your
[ __ ] down yeah oh i thought you meant
that they like crawl into your crowd
like into your bussy like they fall into
your crevices that's a place they could
yeah but no it's that they like stick in
your
sorry uh can i share yet alana i'm
trying to basically it was uh it was so
run down
they were so all the pictures you'd
you'd know just if you saw the pictures
the fire detectors the smoke detectors
had been ripped out of the wall
yeah the carbon monoxide alarm was gone
yeah
and then we're like all right well let's
just chill out and turn on the tv
and then
try to
turn the tv doesn't work
and we're like okay let's just go to bed
and we lay down we're like man it's so
must in here we need to leave the fan on
and we realize that there's only one
light switch attached to both the light
and the fan so i have a video of jacob
like unscrewing the light
and then turning it back on so that we
can sleep so we can at least have some
air air moving
the window there were screams and music
and like there were so many people just
like
like skulking about the hotel it was
yeah like on the races and stuff just
everywhere just hanging out people
having parties like all this [ __ ] john
how much was it at night sixty dollars
as long as you're overcharged
[Laughter]
it'll john i looked at reviews after the
fact and a lot of them complained about
cockroaches oh right we didn't
experience that and i'm glad we were the
name of the hotel what was that what was
the name oh you can't say can you do you
want to put it in chat so i can look at
the reviews uh we
i don't
put it in chat i'm going to see if you
like anonymously oh you've got the link
okay i got the link because there are
some pretty funny reviews there are some
long ones some long boring ones but
there are some pretty look at that
ladies
oh my god thank you there's a lot of a
lot of numbers
okay
here we go
uh the rating of the overall ratings
this is on google
this is on google on book hotels.com or
whatever the [ __ ] it said it was great
oh look there's me all right so here's
jacob looking for bed bugs
what the hell zoom auto full screened
and now it's going to screw up the
recording why did you auto full screen
john you [ __ ] everything up
i didn't do it it's technically the
hotel's fault yeah play no it's over
this too all right all right you good
all right so here's jacob ensuring that
we don't have bed bugs
does it matter if this link is visible
like you have to edit that link out
no no that's fine okay it's not a shared
album gotcha um
here's the sink which had some weird ass
can you see my mouse yep yeah okay
there were like specks of i think there
were burns and stuff like all around
here this is before you guys used it it
had that like as we found it oh my god
as we found out look at the carpet
even that hand towel like that just
sitting there or did you use that i
think no that was just sitting there
john i wish i wish we had known that you
were staying here before you went
because alana and i would have tracked
down a bottle of luminol
that would have been good and you could
have sprayed it to see if the blood came
up under a black light
we would have think that it didn't work
because the entire thing would have been
limited
everything must be opposite luminal yeah
pretty much this was like just a corner
of the room with that
corner which
oh look at jacob look at him
oh my god
this was like that as well i don't know
those are like two they didn't even
clean
maybe they did
this is the corner
right next to the
right next to the shower there's like a
ticket in there or something like that
yeah and a cotton bud and a ticket and
is that all cigarette ash it's got to be
yeah probably
debris
which it's like you step outside you can
smoke outside it doesn't make any sense
they must have been on meth or something
and not want to go outside here's the
light
[Laughter]
there's the ac
uh fire oh my god this place is
just illegal
yeah oh there's me changed the channel
there you go did that work
how's the tv go oh my god it did not it
did not go no it did not um and then
here's jacob
performing an emergency maneuver if it
loads
um of him
well you can just see he's unscrewing
the light bulb so that he can turn the
fan on i'm gonna interject right now as
you talk about this with a quick review
from one user who said
host told me to go f myself after i
asked what their refund policy was this
place is absolutely disgusting getting a
refund asap john
here i got one outlets didn't hold my
charger and it sparked
oh
my car was stolen in the parking lot and
they don't have cameras don't stay here
[Laughter]
like john and i found one that was like
there's a hole in the wall that goes all
the way to the outside
[Music]
oh my god how did you not look into this
john
listen i i i'm a busy guy
i do remember that one year that we we
intended to go to gdc together and you
picked an airbnb
that i was like
okay i guess like it it didn't seem good
to me obviously that got cancelled
because that was covered right so yeah
we couldn't go i'd still like to go next
year we should try and do that um
i've never seen this in a review i'm so
sorry this place is disgusting snot on
the walls
that wasn't that's not yeah there's no
way that's not
sorry alana that's fine but i do
remember john maybe making a bad
decision where that was uh so for any
travel that we do do we maybe don't let
jon pick the accommodation yeah well i
if i recall alana i gave you two options
one of them the cheapest which was scary
yeah and the other one was like
someone's living room
neither were great
but i was like
i trust you i guess i don't it was this
was before i knew that you could even
rent a whole apartment in an airbnb and
not have to meet the host yeah it was
all pretty bad it was all pretty bad um
we did not go are alive it could have
been worse i think we need to give john
another chance third time's the charm
well yeah where are you right now
i am in a beautiful
two-bedroom house
in kansas city there you go
i didn't need both bedrooms
um
because i ended up setting up in the
living room with my setup why um
it's beautiful it's got its own property
everywhere around me is abandoned or oh
it's not abandoned it's just it sounds
bad again john it sounds bad again
there's a river there's like a dirty
river that way
there's a like an empty lot that way and
the house this way is like
it has like construction panels on it
but no one's ever been there so i think
maybe the construction's on hold they're
having issues with the contractors or
something but so there's just no one
around me
and uh i gotta say
no one has been able to escape yet
but you know it
is that's a little it's just you joke
because everyone because rahul said i
look like the ptk killer
do you remember that i think he looks
like
yeah he does look a bit like btk yeah
it's the glasses [ __ ] it's just the
glasses i don't know about that those
are nice bosses john does your key work
my oh yeah my i have a it's a little
keypad with the four digit number
why would you ask if my card
two [ __ ] nerds now jacob look at
these two [ __ ] nerds
you wanna make a gundam anime
hold on a minute
jacob i don't know why we roll with
these two i know
i've got the webcams nice and divided
now we got
a nice
brown hat
on this zoom call very good it is us
um but
what the [ __ ] just happened what are you
talking about
i also didn't know what that was a
reference to but i let him say it i
thought it was the penicillin i started
panicking
rahul and i are on the top are the tops
i get it you said between the two
webcams so i thought you meant like
physically you'd put a hat between two
webcams on your desktop or something and
i was like cool
i thought you were wearing a tiny cowboy
hat and i was like yeah we just couldn't
see out of frame look squinting to see
it it's right up here um but i was
asking about your key working john
because when we came back from visiting
our dear friend bones
1 30 in the morning yeah because we were
trying to avoid getting back to the
hotel as late as possible so we had to
spend as much time on the beds yeah um
but we got to the door and our key cars
wouldn't open it
so we were like uh oh let's get to the
lobby and see what's up and uh john you
had a lovely conversation with the guy
at the desk did i
i don't even remember oh you asked you
told him like we told him like oh our
keys don't work don't open the door and
his response was is there somebody in
the room oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh yes that was frightening uh and then
as we were walking back so he set that
up he said is someone in the room and
then we were walking back we went up the
stairs and someone came out of one hotel
room in front of us and he was walking
walking walking we're like
is this dude walking towards our hotel
room and they ended up turning at the
door right before it but there were yeah
i was convinced he was going to go into
somebody
in your hotel room yeah or if somebody
just got in there they dumped our
luggage somewhere oh and they also had
those like the two adjoining doors you
know or like
connecting hotel rooms so we had our
side locked but like you could hear
people talking through it
anyways
our keys the magnet like died in them an
hour after he gave them things oh my god
yeah it was a little intense yeah but an
event
it was also terrible when we woke up and
we're like okay we gotta go get some
breakfast somewhere and i put my mask on
we should have been sitting out on the
tv stand all night
and it had absorbed
the cigarette smoke
scent and everything oh my god our
clothes our luggage every saturday
we were like
oh that sounds like heaven
yeah
yeah
it was great and you just smell like a
bunch of drugs
bones was delightful
his daughter told me i was battling
video games
said you were bad at video games yeah
she's three
i hope you were unnecessarily aggressive
just like jacob's like out of order
slapped her in the face yeah took it
personally yeah well she she she beat me
in warioware and then ran outside to
where john and bones were and what [ __ ]
what did she say it was so she said i
beat your friend he stinks or something
like she said i was terrible
he's terrible
that's very cute yeah so see she like
just ran out there she's so happy she's
[ __ ] on me mm-hmm
jacob notoriously bad at video games
it's not true it's not true so basically
the whole trip was a disaster
mm-hmm but jacob john it was probably
fine that's how i slept like half the
way back nice i told you i told you
like it was like a six hour drive yeah
like maybe five five and a half hours
and like going up there was fine because
we were just chatting the whole way and
it flew by on the way back it's like the
way back so i'm like john you go ahead
and nap
and um as soon as you receive this again
jacob incredible gripping
incredible [ __ ] yeah as soon as you were
asleep i was like
they're like oh god i'm so tired now
as soon as i fell asleep i heard a
creaking and it was your elbows bending
so that you could lean forward in the
steering wheel no
life comes out
i found one last review that's another
short one sentence of your motel go for
it
disgusting
two broken tvs no channels found pants
behind tv
[Applause]
those kind of like 60 bucks pants
found what are you gonna complain about
finding pants [ __ ] off that's treasure
can you give that one a thumbs down not
helpful yeah the hyatt and that they
give you a robe yeah you know what i
mean you've got pants yeah i would
probably take pants over robes any day
me too why do i need a robe full
that's amazing i go naked anyway john
you're really bad at picking places um
but maybe you've won since you know
going to korea and now having a nice
house yeah well all of that missouri
most of that was after
or
most of that stuff was before the hotel
but yeah i've learned my parents okay
here's a travel tip
if you're in the continental united
states because internationally it
doesn't work because you know who knows
what's going to be whatever what do you
define as continental united states yeah
48 states
is it you doing confederate stuff no
continental united states did not
include hawaii and alaska yeah but
actually that doesn't matter all fitty
um
choose a hotel
brand
and sign up for their hotel app
and book everything through the app
and then message them in the app
community i'm so excited to come for my
stay
um because they all have that
and you get like loyalty stuff
and i and i saw this in like a like
from a hotel employee they said they
love when you message them through the
app you can like ask for upgrades and
stuff they're like oh my god you're
using our app
uh i'm a hyatt i do a lot of hi-editing
really uh any any united airlines
um
my mom
told me it's like the hilton homestead
or something
it's like a
division it's like a subdivision of
hilton
and they gave you breakfast there was
breakfast buffets that at every place i
stayed at it was amazing
they had a [ __ ] waffle machine oh
that's pretty sick i had this problem in
uh in nicaragua where because i didn't
know how to speak spanish
i was kind of unclear on what
food was free and what wasn't there was
a buffet for every meal i think maybe
except dinner there was one for
breakfast and for lunch and it always
looked amazing they had like this buffet
had like these little like chocolate
cakes out every day
i was there for two weeks never had any
of them because i didn't know how to ask
if they were free and i didn't want to
be like can i eat this
so i just
i got around korea for three months
with just google translate and papago
which is a i could have figured it out
but i was too nervous
polite is more the issue is that i was
scared to be like i take without paying
to como manzana well i could say that to
bebe's leche i can also say that
just that's what you should have done
i'm playing through
resident evil 4 in vr right now and they
speak spanish but it's like very mexican
spanish and dude i just keep saying
for every time that i find money
okay alana because everybody's got
treasure
how far into it are you about two hours
okay
it's so do you know what homer simpson
sounds like yes
you will now hear homer simpson
in the game
really that's a threat some of the
voices sound like homer for some reason
like it's like homer trying to speak
spanish i don't know why
oh you made it through the whole game it
was like is that homer i'll keep an ear
out for it it's great whatever my
favorite voice acting in games for npcs
is hitman because no matter what country
they're in like in thailand they'll
still speak cockney english for some
reason so they're like yeah yeah welcome
to the bangkok hotel you [ __ ] yeah i'll
take your luggage
it's like i'm in like the burj khalifa
right now yeah hello and welcome to
japan
we're so happy to have you here in tokyo
today
what
yeah it's definitely it's definitely a
thing thank you
oh my god
i really appreciate that
three dirty americans on this podcast i
have an audition uh
pretty soon for the first time and this
is like a life goal that somebody's
actually gonna let me do a valley girl
in a video game
oh yeah you gotta no you got an audition
of your love all right
must be nice yeah
good for you
what's that face
oh my god i it's
never wanted i've never had any negative
feelings towards you but i just wanted
to punch you in the throat just it was
like that jim carrey
smile
anyway um i'm i'm going to see him
because i'm not oh do you love i'm just
going to pause on it because i couldn't
have the role but i'm very can you send
me the details for that edition because
i do a pretty good valley girl myself
don't you do it no
no i want to save it for my audition
that's true you don't want a friend
she's trying to try to get your some
tips right now jacob you do do an
impression like a valley girl not a star
wars
anything that's not star wars okay
anything what about like i don't know
someone from the banking clan
that's from star wars
jacob
i was trying to find something that
wouldn't either
jacob's a saint and we'll watch anything
you send him most people i think this is
a it's a hard fast rule if you don't
sell me on the [ __ ] link you can't
expect me to view the link i don't over
sell it either
link
you you have admitted
that all the tick tocks i send you lana
you watch i do love them all of you and
i am a great curator you are content
that is true
you personalized clicking a link dm
everyone yeah
i do personalize it and i make sure you
know i've got no [ __ ] time for stupid
dog or cat videos you think i find that
[ __ ] funny i don't find pet [ __ ] funny i
want you to know that [ __ ] that sounds
to me every dog that you send me i then
send to my aunt and uncle who are the
only people over 50 that i know who are
on tick tock so it's very exciting to me
to have this like new platform where i
have family members so i send them every
single dog so just every time you send
me a tick tock with a dog in it i kick
one of their [ __ ] in the
elevator in this building
here's a little update i haven't opened
it
in a hot minute oh my god penicillin
i'm behind on my uh
tick tocks that have been sent to me
let's see my notifications i have 99
notifications
uh let's see wait are they all from john
uh some of them here we go
um two from lindsay uh 11 from tara and
86 from john
it's really good though so
we love you ketchup i've had this one a
day that's like you haven't opened a
week right yeah this is like since my uh
looks like my birthday that's fast oh
wow
i i've had tick tock for about two weeks
and i don't look at the home feed at all
i'm just using it to like make some
extra gaming content so
john you act as my home feed you showed
me the stuff on tick tock that i
wouldn't otherwise see and i'm a big fan
i feel like i should be paying you for
this service
have i ever sent you a youtube link and
said hey watch this
if you have i didn't so i can't remember
it's a no it's so hard to get me to
watch youtube i'm very intentional with
my leak sins
listen you guys for the everyone we
haven't talked about what i sent i sent
the idubbbz documentary called full
force where he goes i doubt you making
content
sort of
i think he works at best by now like i'm
not joking i think he was just like i
want a normal job again and so yeah
idubbbz kind of i remember
some [ __ ] went down
because his girlfriend at the time
started and only fans and so all of the
in-cell supporters that he had were like
no i would never support you a beta cuck
then they were all really upset with him
because his girlfriend had lonely fans
and he was like i'm cool with it
i don't know anything about that i mean
it is 19.99 a month but i don't know
anything about that
uh i think you sent this to me what like
back when it came out back when it came
out yeah yeah so he's done two of those
where he went and he met random
youtubers the first one is he meets
airsoft fatty and he hangs out with him
for a few days around his house and the
second one is he meets
dax flame
who's like one of the og youtubers but
he met him like back in 2019 or 2020
and documents what he's doing now which
is working in an ice cream parlor wow um
i got a very uh oh sorry
well i was just gonna say airsoft fatty
his
channel should be called star wars fatty
because
all he most of his videos apart from
making like uh hot dogs and stuff
um
is him
playing with toy star wars lightsabers
with his friends
and it's him just spouting lore
being like ah
general stixx nice to see you again how
are the things on ketosis
[Music]
yeah and seriously if you guys watch it
you will love it rahul and jacob i wanna
i don't really give a [ __ ]
or not
yeah it is a really good watch it's kind
of it's like almost an hour well jacob i
rewatched it after i sent it to you guys
oh really and i loved it see when
i got the experience of john sending me
links to stuff like back when we worked
in the same office cause i would get a
message from him and i'd see him peeking
over the top of his computers at me
every time because he worked like across
the room for me i got
[Music]
saying something on slack or some [ __ ]
and then waiting to see if somebody
laughs like is one of my favorites i do
it now with uh one of our producers at
work his name's ed if ed's ever in one
of my meetings i'll write something in
like the team's chat while the meeting
is happening and then immediately just
look at ed's camera and be like come on
come on come on let's always be like
like
i did that recently with um uh patrick
because we're all in the office
editing and stuff
and shooting videos and he was talking
about how he like watched doom but like
also came up that he hates animal
crossing
and stuff like that so i immediately
found some like a bunch of people who
had converted their
animal crossing islands into arrakis
nice and i started sending them to him
and i was just watching over my monitor
to see if he started shaking his head
eddie he's a very head-shaky man that
patrick he is yeah but he had a smile on
his face yeah it is definitely a thing
that i miss about working in an office
is just making people laugh this is a
good time that's what something
i'd love to do to jacob oh
is i'd say do you hear that random sound
and he'd say
i do now
and then he wouldn't be able to not hear
it ever again that's rude
well i was i didn't want to suffer alone
a lot
suffering
it's empathy
it's not empathy
it's
empathy with someone if they're not
okay
not
experiencing the same thing as mean as
you right okay exactly yeah you had
trouble empathizing with jacob until he
had the same suffering that you had
exactly
got it so anyway john you road tripped
to kansas city oh my god it was so
eventful was your road trip
it was so eventful
okay uh
first
stop phoenix
i only drove six hours i was going to do
eight
hours a day and make it there in
three days of driving
uh but this girl
wanted to meet up with me
and so i was like all right i'll come is
that the one that you texted me about
no that's a different way
you got tinder or something was it
tinder
and no it was we actually met in
dallas report
not korean
uh
from phoenix
but then
i had a panic attack uh about the whole
trip a few days before i left and i was
like i need to just drive through i need
to get there so i texted her and i was
like i think i'm gonna change my plans
and like 20 minutes later i texted i was
like never mind i'm not changing my
plans
and then when i got to phoenix she was
like oh i left
oh no
oh so i got to stay in this swanky hotel
they had a lazy river
i did not go in it more than 60 dollars
more than 60 dollars yes was it green
i've always wanted to go
so then to catch up i was gonna have to
drive like 12 hours the next day
you're in pursuit yeah yeah oh no
i'm gonna find you
we're gonna go in that lazy river
[Laughter]
but so about two hours into that 12 hour
drive i said [ __ ]
this six hours was a great amount of
time
you make distance but you're not [ __ ]
dying and so i looked it up and
about the six hour mark was albuquerque
and i said all right i'm sitting on
christian i said why are these hotel
prices so expensive oh well i don't want
to drive so i paid for it and then when
i get there she said you in town for the
balloon festival
and i said
and and she was like it's the annual hot
air balloon festival that's why
everybody's in town i was like i didn't
even hear about that she's like
i don't know if i've ever met someone on
the weekend of the of the week of the
hot air balloon it wasn't here for the
hot air balloon festival and i was like
this sounds like an npc in a video game
was she seven years old
she was done 40
i'd say maybe roughly maybe 38. is this
the same girl you missed in phoenix
different woman no this is a this is the
hotel receptionist
i heard this girl wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait it's just
played by the same actor
okay
what
okay
you missed her in phoenix now you're in
albuquerque and she's an albuquerque and
she's like she's coming in view mirror
driving my hyundai elantra
going 90
down the 57
in your hair uh-huh yeah did your trip
your trunk fixed
my trunk is well no here's what i did it
was
the other stuff in my pocket kept
hitting the trunk button and my trunk
kept opening oh my god when john drove
to my house before right before he left
for oakland he was pulled up and his
trunk just popped open
so i just got rid of the dongle when you
unlock the door with your key you can
get into the car yeah but but it's very
peacock of you to do that you show up
places and flip your [ __ ] trunk open
and everyone's like oh damn
or who is it it's a pedophile blushed or
it's a pedophile kidnapping could be one
or the other
what what a restaurant i'm not gonna
kidnap anyone
except jake
[Laughter]
so i was like oh my god she gives me a
brochure and i'm like i gotta check out
this hot air balloon festival
uh so then i slept in and i left i
didn't see any hot airport
in the sky
this is going to be like six in the
morning yeah this is our travel we've
faced an entire podcast around
john's travel adventures
and so far you didn't
hook up with the chick and give us a
romance story you've slept in during the
hot air balls well i also didn't go in
the lazy river which was the whole
reason i booked that place god damn it
this is the worst travel show
that's what sounds dope can we make that
the first thing that we make sure yeah
i mean we have to wait a year yeah let's
do it let's go to albuquerque i've been
to albuquerque have you
i shot a movie there how was it
it's all right
okay well they talk about the movie or
albuquerque it's not really my travel
show i i took over last week with
midnight mass i'm not going to take over
with this we asked you about albuquerque
ever there's no taking over
25
i went to
uh we shot
we shot a movie this year from
january oh oh i told you about it we
took a private jet you know
that was that one
yeah and we went to we went to
albuquerque i think and then we drove it
was a road trip movie so
the idea was we would fly out there and
start filming and any other road
portions we'd get along the way and we'd
make pit stops all the way back to la so
we would drive back to la from
albuquerque and we'd go through new
mexico at certain locations that they
scouted so yeah we started off there
uh and it was [ __ ] cold yeah uh
because it was yeah it was february yeah
yeah january february um
it was
[ __ ] white and [ __ ] cold
and the food sucked the american dream
albuquerque i was so horny i didn't eat
anywhere
i was horny because
go on
jacob might understand this a little bit
okay
we saw a couple of trump flight like
flags
on the way from albuquerque through
and we saw it quite a few confederate
flags
and i got turned on all right okay
because danger i was like oh
if we got out
what's going to happen what if you met
mary sue ellen right and she's like
you know my daddy's racist and my
brothers are raised
for my bossy madame
we gonna make out in the barn
um yeah i can't tell my daddy that i saw
y'all here make sure you keep it a
secret from pop
do i tell you what i'm sorry don't tell
pop that i was talking to brown people
i'll admit i'll admit on our drive up to
my king when i when i we drove past a
few recall newsome signs
oh yeah
i might have got that blood pumping a
little bit you chopped up jacob
where are you from no no like where are
you really from
oh where are your parents from jacob
fullerton
that can't be your last name
obviously
is it pronounced full target
[Laughter]
so anyways albuquerque
it's silent because he's making noise
oh whatever the [ __ ]
i honestly don't know i think i kind of
blacked out there for a second
i don't even remember what he said it
hit me really hard
oh
it's like it was like a dream
is
is fullerton a malice their last name
oh yeah definitely male stare what does
that mean my dad's doing i was trying to
get him to do a malistaire impression
i'm trying to get jacob's star wars
impression under the
under the radar oh that didn't seem very
under the radar i didn't have any i
don't know if i had anything for malissa
to work with other than that there's pod
racing on malista no the congress and
malice
yeah that's right ah [ __ ]
oh jacob got didn't get a [ __ ] start
jacob no more stars i fall apart
i'm following okay it's under pressure i
just like rece like just like last week
i did that the congress of alastair line
for somebody
for like some tick-tock
no it's for work it was for work um but
yeah the first thing i was like oh do
the congress of malistaire thing
um
and i think i think i spent myself okay
so funhouse gets it but we don't
i don't even think they got it because i
haven't gone up anywhere that's fine
i was so hoping i was so hoping you said
that tara had asked for the malistaire
one and that was something that you guys
got into
now she asked for revenge of the sis
stuff now
no hold up
so rahul summary of albuquerque is horny
john's is
you missed the
not enough balloons
has anyone done a white balloon i did
one once
it sounds kind of scary too dangerous
it's really cool it's really hot
like in a way that sleeps yeah a really
[ __ ] open flame right there and it
smells like gas like it and it seems
like obviously it would but it's a thing
that i didn't know before i went on one
when i was a kid that it's like so you
have to kind of lean on it sort of you
don't really want to be too close to it
but it's beautiful because you're
actually you know in an open
space not in a plane or or whatever the
[ __ ]
getting to look out at everything around
you so they take you usually at sunrise
because it's the most beautiful view
they are were you in a group were you
with someone or you were you in a creep
yeah yeah it's a huge group yeah no
she's favorite alone
were they all white yeah
i would actually say probably not i
would think it was probably pretty
tourist heavy
is it scary at all
so high up i don't remember being scared
i'm scared that there's a basketball
basket in the sky yeah i'm scared that
the basket's not because
like especially because i'm tall they
say any kind of railing if it's not if
it's below your hip you you're going
over it like that yeah it's yeah it's
got to be above your hip and that basket
looks like no they're huge
what it's going to come up my it's going
to be over my hair they're massive well
maybe yeah it'd be over your hip yeah
that's why i always do the lizard on the
balconies
what's the lizard
that's pretty slither
you know you've seen it i've done it on
your balcony what
what
slither like a lizard what are you
what
so i don't fall over the railing what
you're not making it make more sense
yeah you're making it less sense you
don't
listen you guys know i'm very tall and
if i go near any railings my hips
are above the very much above the
railings and your [ __ ] touches the
ground floor yeah
it's like a crouched down giraffe
very similar to a lizard if you've ever
seen lizards when they run
yeah oh i see what you mean
like on the outside yeah and it's
skitter
you're more of a bearded dragon
baby dragon bearded dragon oh bearded
dragon that's still cool and they wave
mushrooms and i looked in the mirror and
i thought i looked like a pink bearded
dragon that's tight did you feel
pleasantly about it at the time
well i didn't i didn't actually look
like a dragon but i was imagining i was
looking i was looking in the mirror
what's up
imagining trying a cartoon
pink dragon in my defense for the
malistaire thing oh [ __ ] i was um
my thought process was i have to clear
this up or i'll never live it down um
this is gonna not gonna be a good
defense for anybody um i was trying to
think of lines spoken by a doug
since they're native to malistaire but
all the lines are getting like like like
it's a bobas yes the bulb is a dug and
especially dangerous doug
um who's making a joke about doug
it's canadian like the cartoon
the dog the dog we've spoken about on
the show previously oh that's john
john's doug johnstuck who yeah
doug
friend of the show doug doug
uh she's not a friend of the show yeah i
was trying to think of a line spoken by
a doug but they're all in hoodies and i
didn't want to offend anybody so
you don't want to offend anybody
just done it
yeah you could have asked me jacob
seeing as you're now the the the the
you've been relegated and now i'm top
star wars fan if you wanted a a
a line from a dog
wow oh that's [ __ ] good
very good
don't do this again
it's very
good i can't do that again
is that borax
no it's qui-gon
it's don't do that again
i like john's fashion
don't better that again
very good
there's the impression
goes
hard
we're watching different kinds of star
wars i think you're watching on a
different website this is george's
vision
it probably was yeah so you left
albuquerque yeah i left albuquerque i
stayed in i don't even remember i i
think it was called
liberal
kansas
which was ironic
um
but
what i will say is that arizona and
nevada i saw so many coyotes
that had been torn in half it was it was
gory
just on the side of the road because
they had been they
tried to run across the road got just a
semi or something
and just like not just like you see a
dead animal it was like
like
frightening
jesus
yeah hyper violent just driving down the
road oh there's eviscerated corpses free
food though
oh my god
you've just given me a memory that i
completely forgot
some magic
yeah i
i can't believe i forgot this
you know the night i told you where i
knocked my tooth out on midnight mass so
it was my monologue day i knocked my
tooth out
bly manor came out on the way home i hit
a skunk
or a raccoon
full on on the freeway
did you pull over and help it
no because i want to go home check
twitter
and i was worried i didn't want to look
because i it ran into me
so
i was
yeah [ __ ] and like the force it
really does like it it does feel
horrible
i'm sure it's worse for them
but i didn't check i just carried on so
i was like well you play stupid games in
it so
i drove for an hour
back home
and
there was a part of me when i pulled up
i was like should i at least check that
i haven't been dragging half a raccoon
just in trails because i wouldn't want
to look and i had a peek and there was a
few spots but um
he must have dislodged
because i checked the rear
sorry as like intro it as though you
were like super stoked
to have
something i'm so excited
making a joke of it i can't remember
what it was but it was like every time i
i feel like i've done a good job i
sacrifice an animal oh
good one
again penicillin rahul just hits
different he is in another place is it
he oh he's gonna od on ibuprofen
yeah i've never done that but it seems
real sad but also like it's definitely
i'm sure i've said before a thing in
australia where if you hit a kangaroo
you're gonna die and the kangaroo will
just hop away because it's just muscle
because they're ripped
have you seen the video of the guy
punching the kangaroo oh yeah because up
to it there are a few just like because
it had it had a dog in a headlock
oh yeah it just got really good he saw
it and he runs across and yeah he just
spoke i do that for my dog
i do that he's just like your dog he's
just like hey
and then he just runs over there and
like starts boxing with it he gets it
this statement
like boxes stance kind of because they
lean back on the tails and they just
kind of go for it but
the kangaroo after it gets punched it's
just like
yeah it's so confusing yeah it's never
been punched before i i wonder how many
kangaroos have been punched in the face
by humans
i reckon
kangaroos versus any other kind of
animal pretty [ __ ] high up there
because it's in australia and because of
like they're kind of punch level to you
and because they're ready for a fight
i disagree i think the most punched
animal on the planet's a horse
who's punching horses because they're
police horses and i've seen it in
football matches i've seen like
hooligans head butt horses punch horses
because they're police horses jeez what
the hell is wrong with your stupid
country football all right well so we've
got a nominee of the animal most punched
animal from australia and one very
specific to to english football john
what's your name that's not english
football just anyone with police horses
i feel because europe does that too i
feel like they're there
you don't like i've seen one police
horse one time ahab
[Laughter]
look up your stupid face
oh [ __ ]
um can we have two more nominees and
we'll take a vote in the comments or
which animals and punches can we name
this one
can you localize it like pick one from
like your hometown or some [ __ ] most
punched animal in kansas city right now
all right my dick nice uh mama yeah
[ __ ] yeah wait okay well john's dick
i'll take no it's device
yes no it's locked in it's like all
right it's locked in jacob i didn't
realize i thought it was sexier but it's
sure
shark people love punching sharks sharks
are pretty good bet because i know
whatever to see okay i think shocking
count is quite rare but if i were ever
to see a shark or like try to be
attacked by it i would go for the that's
what everybody tells you to punch it
punch it yeah suppose you punch the
snooze it just goes
like punch it right there right on the
amp the sonar has problems well you
punched him right in the ampullae of
lauren's it's their most sensitive spot
what was that
ampullae of lorenz
something about ziti
yeah it's their electro scent electro
sensing nodes in their nose and they
used to
sends the electrical signals in any
living creatures around that's so
[ __ ] cool i'm sorry but if you've got
if you've got the guts to punch a shark
in the face
i think that that shark should become
your pet i would absolutely punch a
shark in your face like in it it should
be like all right take me home
no but it's not you don't go up to a
shark and punch it in the face you do it
as defense if a shark's gonna attack you
you punch it in the face so i would
think most people would have the balls
to do that because it's survival
well i mean that's a little fire flight
conversation and i think we should have
that
get in the tank
i think do that in front of the kids
have any of you
been in a fight or flight situation
and did you fight or flight like
have you been threatened where it's like
i either have to run or i have to defend
myself
[Music]
yeah i guess i think so yeah
i've been one of
i might have already told you guys about
it should i tell you about the haunted
house i was in
shock
can i do a new top five impression
and then john
discovered something truly
weird you have to go he's more shaky
totally terrifying oh you're right you
know that
and what happened next
shocked even
[Laughter]
yes i saw it you [ __ ] slowed down on
it and put a circle over it
yeah we saw the dude's mate walk past
the door the best one is not a werewolf
i swear to you
the best one's always and they didn't
know until viewers pointed out what was
in the mirror yeah
until reviewing the footage later
what i love about that is
one of the biggest tells
about
the you know any of the top fives
is each country has its go-to thing that
they keep replicating so you'll find
that when it's japanese for instance
it's always a woman it's always got long
hair it's almost ringu-esque
um
when it's
um
latinameric like the you know that it's
usually a child they all follow these
culture like you'll never you won't see
them share these these ghosts
which is why i call [ __ ] on it and i
feel like with america it's always old
lady there's always old lady there's an
old lady it's a grandma you're right it
is often an old lady yeah it's the
governess it was this kind of crap
sorry those are real
tell us your ghost story now you've been
beautiful are you sure i didn't tell you
about this
furry man and the doppelgangers
oh just sounds kind of familiar now i
don't remember i'm sure i told jake
about it at some point you might have
told me i didn't tell it on this podcast
okay do you want the long version of the
short version
a medium with nuke five type stuff
sometimes oh i can i can queue that up
okay
so
there's this family
we'll call them the dumps it's a
it kind of rhymes with their real last
name but it's not their real last name
the trumps
the dumps
so it's the plunks i i i won't be able
to it's their name's plunk um he gave up
on that real fast yeah
they live in whatever [ __ ] matter
um
and they were in my musical theater
group uh when i was in high school and
there was four daughters in the mom
uh and the mom had been separated from
the husband but the husbands didn't
punch these stories so they had all
these stories all these supernatural
stories
uh that they would tell and they would
corroborate with each other
and myself and everyone else in our
friend group was like oh it's like an
inside joke that they have where they're
like pranking everyone with these
stories
um
but then years later
i found out that they had like
burned all their harry potter books and
now refused to tell any of those stories
and so it was like well that is weird
i thought it was all just made up
um and so
here's i'll just give you two of the
stories
what happened was we well this is what
happened
uh when she's
you know when she's telling the story
you know rahul carlos carla gagino yeah
yeah good in blind manner
okay so the telling of the story took
place at their house when we did a
sleepover because it was you know it was
uh
i forget like dress week or hell week or
whatever leading up to the premiere
and so we all all stayed over there
and at some point she sat us down and
she started telling these stories that
we'd heard little tidbits of but she
started telling the full story and the
first one was about this little
creature that had haunted them
um
so basically they lived in texas
and one night when the youngest daughter
was like three years old um
the mom
felt a hand like on her arm when she
woke up and you know the daughter would
come and be like i want water or
whatever and she rolled over and she
said she was face to face
with this creature it almost looked like
cousin it but it had big black beady
eyes and a little
this is what she says a little green uh
like peter pan hat almost like
that makes sense
um with long lanky
hairless arms and feet legs
and she said even though
she saw this like creature
it didn't instill fear in her it was
just she was surprised slash confused
and then she said it was also confused
when it saw her and then it backed
against the wall she said it flattened
against the wall and then it faded out
and there was just like a little
silhouette and she got up and touched it
and it was freezing cold and then she
was like it was just like a like a night
terror not a night terror but like you
know i was in between waking dreaming
she goes back to bed she doesn't think
about it at all weeks go by um
and she's putting her daughter to bed
uh and her daughter goes i don't want to
go in there she's like why not she's
like the hairy man's in there she was
like
what the [ __ ]
um and so she brought it up with her
husband her husband was like [ __ ] off
yeah over the course of like the 10
years that they lived in that house all
four kids
and the wife had multiple experiences
with it seeing it dancing around without
talking to each other about it
no no like they'd
bring it up and they'd be like i saw the
hairy thing
um and then finally when they were
moving out they had all the moving boxes
and everything stacked up and the dad
was watching football and saw things
skidding around and thought it was one
of his daughters but then at one point
caught a glimpse and it was a little
hairy thing
anyways they moved to san diego
never saw it again it was in that house
or whatever but then
this lady is a hairdresser she was
cutting this lady's hair a lady uh with
family mexico and she's like please pray
for my daughter down in mexico they
think she's been possessed
and she was like oh my god like what
happened she's like well she's kept
saying she was seeing this uh creature
in the mirror in the bathroom that
uh
kept asking to be your friend
she's like oh that's so weird and she's
like yeah the creature was like
covered in hair but had these black
beady eyes and a little green cap um
and
she said she dropped her barber scissors
or whatever and was just like
oh my god
uh so her theory is that
it was a demon living in a house and it
was just really bad at its job because
it they lived with it for 10 years and
it didn't possess anybody useless demon
yeah so why did you just wanted to maybe
just wanted a haircut
what maybe it just wanted a haircut
maybe you just wanted a haircut that is
a that is a good point
um so the other ones why did they blame
harry potter
that's just one of like 12 stories that
she told oh all this stuff all this
crazy [ __ ] like when they moved into the
house that they were in
they think that someone
kept the keys and was like sneaking into
their house because they were hearing
people walking around in it and on
halloween one of the daughters woke up
and she was like nine and her friend was
in the bed too and there was like a
clown
standing in their doorway
and they like looked at it and it like
smiled and waved and then walked down
and then like latched the door
um but then another supernatural one is
that they kept seeing doppelgangers of
each other
oh my god
yeah
uh and
uh the weirdest one was that because
everyone including two friends that
corroborated it were all sitting around
the dining table doing like homework or
whatever and then you're doom
um
and
the mom
runs past them
runs out to the garage and slams the
door to the garage they're like what the
[ __ ]
and then 10 seconds later
she comes running down the stairs again
and goes what is it what is it because
for her
she was up in her bedroom and she said
she was just overcome with this feeling
of like dread like if i don't get out of
this room right now i'm gonna die and so
she sprinted down the stairs
and comes to find all her kids like
freaking out and they're like she's like
what's wrong what's wrong
and that was one of the doppelgangers
they had a bunch of others wow
anyways harry potter
that's just a few of the stories and so
they just i think they decided that
their family was cursed
and so they stopped
telling all that stuff because when she
was
done with all these stories she was like
you know i really don't like telling
these stories because
uh it always seems like when we tell
them things start to happen again
um and so this is at a party and when
she started telling stories i'd say only
like half the people were sitting there
uh but slowly over the course feels like
over an hour or two she was telling all
these intriguing stories people slowly
started coming down from upstairs
settling in listening
um and after
she told all these stories we're all
just kind of sitting there shocked in
silence
uh and we hear boom boom up above and
we've been hearing that the whole time
but i
look around and i go
hey is anyone still upstairs
uh and this guy lorenzo goes
uh
me and courtney were the last two people
to come downstairs i don't think
anyone's up there
and then everyone was kind of looking
around here
um and everyone starts screaming and
like running around
and i
fight or flight i sprint up the stairs
and start throwing open doors trying to
find that goddamn ghost
and then i swing open the door to the
bathroom and written in red dripping
letters are the words i love my girls
and i was like you're [ __ ] me
and i fell backwards
um and then
oh fight doctor um can we sense her
first name yeah uh she comes up and she
looks and she goes oh we're repainting
the bathroom i i did that and i was like
oh okay
sure
yeah my god by the way john when you
were telling the story what happened
uh noises started coming from my bedroom
oh
and the doors are cracked and i kept i
couldn't stop for feeling like i saw
something
in the dark so
i was getting yeah
but i heard that's why i was like well
that's weird because no one's here uh
so
is that why you
yeah it's fair and it was distracted
because i kept feeling like over there
john's fight mm-hmm mm-hmm uh i think
well i mean i just want to reiterate
three stories we always thought were a
prank
but
supposedly they all actually believe
those stories which is
like the family believes them
yeah because they burned all their books
and they refused to tell those stories
anymore because they think they're
cursed i want their email address so i
can
write them all down but i feel like they
would say no
they are they had so
many stories
it was crazy sounds good
yeah i was going to say are there
something's running in their family
where they penicillin baby
[Laughter]
and i we fight
yeah jacob you said you had a story as
we just saw
yeah the only one i could think of is
like we drove up to
visit tara's parents
i don't know like five years ago or
something
and uh we got to her house and she has
this uh husky super adorable
name zoey so i was like oh let's go in
the backyard let's see here i think she
was out like on a walk or something but
we went in the backyard little would do
we know that i guess her friend's dad i
think it was yeah her now her dad's
friend was staying with them
and his dog cooter was in the backyard
hooter is the name for vagina in
australia yes that's what i said
immediately upon learning the name of
this dog
his name was cooter did was cooter
offended
it seemed like it so we went in the
backyard looking for the dog didn't know
that this dog was there
and this like terrifying dog just comes
around the corner like we like shut the
glass door and stuff and we're in the
backyard this dog runs around the cord
it's like
it's like growling and barking and stuff
and i'm like am i about to get my throat
torn out
um
so i think like that's the only time i
can remember i was like it's like just
go back inside and jacob let's go and
yeah and then i know i fought this dog
to the death no i went back inside it
was it was it would be fine but i was
actually shut up actually very scared
yeah thanks cooter for not killing me
yeah no i freeze um in situations where
bad things happen i just freeze so i'm
dead
don't worry just stand behind me okay i
had something weird happened i just
remembered
um
me and my boys i
back in the uk the mandem
i lived across the road from a cemetery
that's
where i grew up and my parents still
live
and um
there's like a
the little car park area
is where we would smoke cigarettes and
[ __ ] when we were a bit young just out
of the way so the parents didn't see us
yeah weed we used to smoke a lot of weed
there and one night
uh
the boys myself and my cousin
we were
they were smoking a joint i wasn't
uh
they were
anyway
in the cemetery
the building and it was like three four
in the morning it was pitch black but
there was a light on in the cemetery
at the back in the building
and
they were like oh [ __ ] look what like
who's up at this time like what's going
on over there there's a bunch of kids
and the boys and my cousin climbed over
the fence into the cemetery to go up to
the building at the back and see what
was going on
in the building anyway
i freaked out i thought they were being
[ __ ]
and i was like i'm not taking i'm not
going in and they were like obviously
trying to go to me to get in anyway i
walked home
and then later on they came back knocked
for me and they were like no nothing was
there we couldn't see in but i freaked
out i'm not interested and then the next
day
so i went to bed and then i had that
same dream again
only this time
when i the same thing played out but
when i walked home
someone was standing in front of me with
sunglasses and they shot me in the face
and i woke up in the days
right well then i was like that was
[ __ ] weird i go downstairs
make a cup of tea and the doorbell rings
and the police arrive
and the police
wanted to ask a question i cannot
remember for the life of me what the
[ __ ] question was but they are
something and they left whatever card
and i had a little walk up and they had
forensic tents in the cemetery
the next what and i never found anything
out but i just remember it just being a
very weird like you dream of murder
maybe that's wild i don't know but i
don't know
a murder you need to start writing your
dreams down and solving like rhymes like
before they happen
should should we do the stevie weeby
dream log
you know bobby lee's brother right
took shower did poop and shower legs cut
off sewn back on
dreams are total nonsense like i get mad
whenever anyone's like i had a crazy
dream and then they tell it to me and
they're like trying to recall it because
to them it's fascinating but if it
doesn't have sex in it i don't care if
you're like and then i went for this
walk and there was a beautiful butterfly
everyone's just like did you [ __ ]
something
yeah but what if you're what if you're
the person they [ __ ]
yeah i think they should still well oh
look if they're still telling the story
you can include that but don't come to
me and be like i had a dream where i
[ __ ] you that would be weird i think
what if they went hey
so i had a dream
we boned
the head that was in my dm somewhat
frequently
oh
god oh [ __ ]
one time i had a sex stream that i had
sex with uh a guy who was my manager
when i went to the call center who was a
man that i was very unattracted to like
it wasn't just
like he was fine i was like not at all
attracted to him and i still can't
figure out why that happened it was not
a good time for me i don't know why it
happened at all and i woke up and i was
just like oh
who put this in my head well
it's probably not it's not to do with
sex did the manager have power over you
or something yeah he was super rude so
my guess is that it was like well your
brain just like mashes [ __ ] together
with dreams right so it's like
something sex-related and then this dude
and it just sort of and i was like
here we are
i told you recently i'm not naming names
i'm not saying how i know this person oh
have you made somebody squirt
what yeah there's someone i have zero
attraction to they are
no you're saying too much
bleep that then
two beliefs okay so great someone i know
not attract to them
whatsoever
anyway
i
was on the show i was shooting this
pilot and it was hot
and
the ac didn't work and i was in the
trailer for 13 hours right
in a tux and i was just sweating and i
kind of like had one of them like pass
out heat sweet sleep so i was a little
bit feverish
and in the dream
this person came in and started
breastfeeding me
like a baby and i was just sucking on
the tea
breastfeeding
and then
they
took my hand i think or they did
something
and
they made me
feed the horse
right
and then they squirted all over the
trailer because i was still in the
trailer
and it covered it it was like
ghostbusters 2.
right
i've got lana i told you about this
so i'm telling the truth right this this
i really dropped this
and then it was so and also all her
[ __ ] juice was dripping off the ceiling
right and it was on my costume and i was
panicking
so i spend the rest of the dream
like panic cleaning [ __ ] juice
off the [ __ ] floor off my costume off
my face it's on the [ __ ] it's still
dripping and the more i try and clean it
just it feels like the more [ __ ] juice
is there none of this i just imagine i
just imagine you
in real life
asleep in your
in your trailer going
[ __ ] juice
[Music]
uh yeah she spiderman me and then
i woke up
like in a state of frantic kind of like
panic
and more dehydrated than i've ever felt
in my life so i don't know if the liquid
i don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
but i remember like thanks a lot yeah
because i fell asleep and i fell asleep
in the tux in a closed trailer in the
middle of la with no ac
so i like hot boxed myself because i
remember the first thing i did before i
like needed to erase it and get over the
because it was with someone i really
didn't want to see that way the first
thing i did was like
yeah
and then i was like felt sick about the
physical yes
you need water exactly i heard it
referred to as feeding the horse before
really fantastic no that's what i've
never heard that before well you feed a
horse like that so your hands don't get
fit you dummy have you not had a horse
before i love it when they do that to
the [ __ ]
rahul uh i feel like you forgot you
forgot that last part of the story we
were like man that was a crazy dream and
then you smell your fingers and you go
and there's one
soul
drop of [ __ ]
like we said spiderman spiderman spider
ninja
spider what is that you got spiderman
why does it smell like fish
so john you left albuquerque
oh that's right all right yeah oh yeah i
left albuquerque i stayed in liberal
kansas it was a dump i mean it was fine
it was there was just nothing
um there was like one restaurant that i
went to
and i ordered a fish and it was
delicious i will have one fish please
sir
i bought some mocks
there was a
on their sign it said indian market
uh and they were named american but i
guess just for marketing reasons they
have to keep
those
fronts up or whatever but i bought some
mocks
because they're not indians
oh they're not
a native american
because the feathers on their head you
idiot
yeah i was gonna say
i saw that yeah she was doing the dance
and she lost her job right no she's just
on paid leave hmm
was the ultimate warrior native
i don't understand any part of that
question you like used to watch
wrestling oh
didn't he used to like do
i don't know anything about that
wasn't he blonde i don't i don't know
who he is ultimate warrior anyways yes
they were native american
uh
i'm fairly certain
uh like not what accent did they have
were they like
it was sound came in here john what do
you want
or was it
the other one good good good
very good
no no
uh cause there was a sign that said pay
cash for gas here and i said can i use
my card uh at the at the gas station
yeah that's fine
so that was yeah it was kind of an
arizona accent that is pretty sure
yeah human
that is fine
young one
but he was younger than me so i didn't
understand it
this is the worst one we've done in it i
lost
herpes and
[ __ ] it out john just did an impression
penicillin man those are great it was a
great place i supported them i bought
gas and i bought some mocks which is
short for moccasins they come with
moccasins is a native american word for
shoe
i'm not sure cool there i'll show you my
moc i can't wait to see your marks bro
oh what jacob jacob jacob jacob what
cute
they got fur inside they're very nice
minnetonka is like a national brand so
they weren't handmade at the indian
market devastating but fair
yeah and also you know you'd think the
furry inside will warm you up but if you
wear them without socks your feet gets
so cold i don't know why oh yeah yeah
yeah because it makes your feet sweat or
something huh
yeah and then your sweat foot gets cold
yes wet foot you get cold sometimes yeah
it's comfy looking though um
if you want a really good
furry boot i bought an ugg boot for men
really oh and it's waterproof
a waterproof
boot for men
daisy ridley that
uh it's a actually so it's a waterproof
ugg boot for men the outside is
completely waterproof the inside is like
sheepskin are you talking about oh the
the canada boots
yeah the ones i use during filming can
you wear them without socks
it's very important to john
he likes sweat foot aspire yeah
i want to get some tips from you guys
i've been thinking about shaving my feet
okay
you got hobbit feet
i have hairy feet and here's you
i can't wear socks 24 7 because after
about
nine to 12 hours of wearing socks the
hair follicles on my feet and toes start
to get irritated
start to take my socks off
yeah and then i have to rub i have to do
this
with my heels and my toes i'm are you
maybe wearing so no you're wearing
bombass
i was going to say are you wearing socks
that are too tight but you wear bombas
i wear bombas so i don't your feet must
be really hairy because i've got hairy
feet i've never had the hair follicle
or i'm just sensitive wax
i'll tell you one thing about socks
though
uh you know the part around the ankle
for some reason i don't know what's
wrong with me
it stopped hair growing there
oh
so i got leg hair and then where the
ankle would be of a sock it just killed
all hair that's probably like the tight
part just ruined the hair fibers or
something when you get a bigger sock
or starting you can't because it will
just fall down tonight
and yeah i don't know in it anyway i
think you waxed your feet how did we get
here
oh yeah so you left
i mean that that was just the last drive
i left liberal drove six hours got to
kansas city checked in my airbnb they
got a little key code
that's the best i've been thinking my
brother
uh owns a couple of houses here he
bought them dirt cheap because they're
run down cash but a certain amount of
what cash money smith they call them
yeah cash money real estate cash money
sailor smiths at instagram.com also also
known as uh fishbot
yep oh yeah
um if anyone hasn't seen that video you
should go to sailor smiths on instagram
and you can see a video of my brother
uh he was swimming uh he's currently
traveling the world with his family they
bought a catamaran
no he's not rich
he's just invested in things he just has
a catamaran
they sold their house and bought a
catamaran
um well that's one more house than any
of us have yeah can you is it a baby
they're also in their mid-30s and they
both have had full-time jobs
anyways
ram up his butt and he wanted to make a
video about it so he videoed it and he's
like but i'm going to set the fish free
and so he threw it in the water and it
just
he 100
killed the fish a fish swam up his butt
into his underpants into his swimsuit
yeah they get scared that's my
fight-or-flight response they throw up
their own guts yeah they vomit up all
their guts out that doesn't seem very
efficient
yeah like if you get mugged just drop
your pants and [ __ ] like you shake your
stomach out actually that would work
people would be like oh [ __ ] that
there's confusion no but pearl fish will
swim into sea cucumber [ __ ] to live
there and it's cozy yeah i figure yeah
it is isn't there a fish that
swims up your um urethra yeah
about this for some reason this is the
second conversation during this podcast
that has triggered this it happens in
round the twist the australian show
yes
but i think i may have ever felt like
this how strange
i just remember you found special
underwear that's the only episode i
remember
you know they they released it in the
united states did they so you started tv
when i was a kid i saw that [ __ ] on tv
no way do you know what we used to watch
the is it alice matt alice mack we all
wanted to oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
from boy meets well man then wanted to
[ __ ] dick that down too you get me
i love it jacob said me too
yeah i also had a crush on alice smack i
think
she looked like i don't remember
she wear a beanie
i love a [ __ ] and a beanie did any of
you see the um 30 good deeds of eddie
mcdowell
what the
what did i i don't know how nobody else
has heard of this show what's it called
30 good deeds
eddie
eddie murphy
eddie mcdout it's 100 30 d's it's 100
deeds forever
and i can't any time i ever bring it up
everyone's like what the [ __ ] is this so
100 deep threatening mcdonald is an
american people don't even have it are
you sure
about
eddie came out immediately eddie
mcdonough i found it i found it i said i
put andy or whatever
eddie it's an american tv show created
for nickelodeon and it was greens about
yeah it was i felt like it was huge but
what do i know i guess um and
it's about this guy who was a bully
and as a result
after bullying a kid he gets caught by
some kind of mystical man and he
punishes him by turning him into a dog
and as a dog he must do 100 good deeds
for others to be turned back into a
human so it was a show about like it's a
dog show a narrated dog
it's like wishbone i kind of remember
this i don't think i ever watched it
seth green voices
eddie
initially and then jason herbie um it's
only got two imdb pieces of trivia
is that bad it just says the drifter's
real name was never revealed
what means something to you
and morgan kibby gwen is now a
successful singer-songwriter member of
the ramanov's an m83 m83 isn't that that
mexican gang oh yeah yeah
and maybe three is that game that rules
east hollywood that's nice you're right
congrats
she's making waves out here oh she well
she used to be in a hundred deeds now
she's
m83 i don't know
troubling childhood what
no go ahead i was gonna say i just don't
know how i saw it and how nobody else
seems to even recognize that this show
exists it's weird did you used to watch
eerie indiana
i remember it existing saying i don't
give a [ __ ] it's an australian shepherd
siberian husky mix which sounds cute
did you ever watch so weird
yes
are you afraid of the doc was also are
you afraid of the banger oh that was
good yeah are you afraid of the dog
i love you
which one goosebumps which one had the
um dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
the dog's eyes go
there were some episodes of goosebumps
that as a kid like really messed me up
like i was
shook by the one where they put a mask
on and then can never take it off
oh god oh that yeah that was one of
those actual scary ones that's the jedi
panic attack ever inside of a mask
really yeah and cub scouts on halloween
i dressed up we found this like monkey
it was just like a it was like a
realistic detailed chimpanzee
and it was one of those rubber floppy
ones that smell like [ __ ] on the inside
yeah so i had that on and i think i had
my karate ghee on because i did like
once one
level of karate
um
and we were all in a circle we were all
saying our hellos and then when we broke
like three different kids ran over to me
and were like oh my god your mask is so
cool like it looks like a monkey
um
and being surrounded by everyone
unable to breathe like smell things with
my face i just went
and then just like ran through them and
then went and just was like crying on a
couch
and my dad came over i take the mask off
and i can't wear full headed masks
anymore that happened to uh
anthony daniels in return of the jedi it
did when yeah
when he had the salacious crumb on his
face
like attacking his head then he had like
a panic attack while this monster muppet
was eating oh my god and
you can't just like
unzip that suit yeah people gotta get
you out of it
i know uh um therma had one
and killed bill
and she was buried alive yeah she when
she was born oh god she had a panic
attack i had a panic attack on stage
they do often seem to be related to
claustrophobia
or lighting
yeah mine was induced mine was induced
through nerves
the
first time i went to drama school i'd
never acted before i'd had never had any
type of training we can tell at
like 18
19
i went to this club i got accepted into
this class
and
there were 30 of us and we all sit down
for class one
and the teacher's like okay uh to kick
things off
everyone has to perform a scene right
now on their own improvised uh you
discover a dead body
and you have to come on discover it do
what you want and then leave
and he just starts from random person
and then just works his way around the
circle that we were sitting in and it
was the most terrifying thing to think
of it now
at 36 i mean i was 19 but like to think
of how afraid i was when it was my turn
to just
walk onto stage and pretend i found a
dead body anyway
uh when it finally was up to my turn and
i stood in front of 30 year olds
that year old's 30 people varying
ages a terrifying 18 year old 30 year
olds as an 18 year old i was terrified
my poor bussy but i um
yeah i
i managed to work the nerves i managed
to work myself into a panic attack
did you use that for the scene i did use
it yeah so
i went in freaked out
ran out
it was really cool
and i never went back to that acting
class again
but that that it was a frantic scene it
probably wasn't any good but it like
yeah and at the time i was suffering
from panic attacks quite regularly
um they sound super scary i think i've
maybe only had one
i used to get them in the tube a lot on
the train
oh
and then once it's like you know the
door's shut i'd be like that all i'd
need the voice in my head to do is go
now would be a bad time to have a panic
attack in it oh my gosh
and i always feel like they like so
anyway through drama
weirdly through constant nerves through
every lesson standing up performing
performing performing
the control of nerves which never goes
away helped me manage panic attacks
early and cut and nip him in the bud
because i'm it's almost that that that
feeling
is so almost relatable now to what i do
as a profession
that i can i won't go past that point
now with panic attacks so i can i can
just register it chill relax and bring
me right back down because i'll still
get that voice like i'll be on a plane
and once we
once the doors are shut that voice goes
same voice that used to like freak me
out 1819 that claustrophobia being
locked in and going
you don't want to have a panic attack
right now there's no way you could go
i still get that now but i i can just be
like
especially if you're sitting backwards
on a private plane on a private jet yeah
of which i catch many it would be
extremely painful
for you
yeah
[Music]
i think he did a great job
it's bane john from the batman
batman batman
you know why she's doing this because
you say englishman
oh whoa that looks really weird what the
[ __ ] i only like
about it i don't like the red hood
animated film i don't like any other
batman that's very specific but also
great
just the redwood one it's a good one
year one your one was okay yeah there is
no way you don't like batman and robin
the movie yeah
i used to meet me
wait what's this yeah ice to meet you
nice to meet me nice to meet you it's a
lot of it might be ice to meet me
does he ever have a line that isn't a
pun that's what i want to know really 10
out of 10. cool
they got that one
thing
um
hey wouldn't it be like crazy to be in a
plane crash
like i know people are scared of it but
whenever i'm on a plane i and we hit
turbulence ago this would be a very
unique experience that very few people
are
valuing my trip higher by giving me a
unique
experience what would you do yeah do you
ask that to the person next to you
i would
i would want to look out the window and
i'd want to see the planet coming
towards
well i think i mentioned before that
i've done that vomit comet which is
uh-huh you nose-dive on a plane oh yeah
and they tell a lot of people not to
look outside the window because it is
pretty scary to look at i only looked
once because it's hard not to when
you're told not to you are nose-diving
to the ground so you look outside the
window and earth is like that yeah it's
very very weird to look at i can't wait
yeah i don't think i'm actually very
afraid of dying my thought is always
how long can i live if a plane goes down
for me to be able to text my family and
tell them that i love them every time
i'm thinking about it there's bad
turbulence i'm like okay if we start
going down i know how dare i
how how how close do i have to be to
cell towers to send off a text and will
i still be conscious at the range where
i'm
close enough to a cell power so
everyone's screaming and you're just
like come on bars come on bars
exactly that's my whole whole game of
math thing it's because you're dead
right the chances of you living are so
slim
yeah yeah a big passenger plane yeah
you're pretty much [ __ ] yeah okay i
found the script for a movie called
alive
yeah okay which is based on a true story
sorry ryan reynolds
so alive is about a rugby team it's okay
so it's
okay so
i haven't seen it but a plane crashed
and it had a uruguayan rugby team
in it and they crash in the middle of
the andes uh and they are they have to
try and survive and they end up eating
some of the dead bodies they cannibalize
to survive yeah
gotta do what you gotta do
yeah so i was looking to see if there
was a script for free so we could just
read the plane crash part
extra content patreon just just for
patreon but uh it's too hard to find
with no notice but i was going to try
and us i did also just text all of you
recently about um wanting to create
i won't even say what it is because i
feel like oh yeah yeah
it was a good idea but basically like a
comedy schedule that i think is is quite
good the problem is i don't really want
to i don't really want to do acting on
camera because it's like sort of
bringing home your work with you do you
know what i mean like
oh do you act
i was just curious about like the outfit
i might have to wear oh you need to wear
an outfit jacob yeah
yeah i'd say i i
would want everyone would need to be a
character it's up to everybody to pick
what character they would be don't i
already know exactly i've got a whole
backstory i also have a whole backstory
planned i think it would be great
is it going to be written or is it going
to be all improv i think we probably do
it uh like a cub your enthusiasm where
we write what needs to happen but then
improv it while it's happening nicely so
we can have things written that's and
where i'm in my element i know you're so
good at improv it's crazy i am not
i'll use those bullet points we can well
yours you will have less lines
but very important physicality
yes i was when you told us about it i
was the only one who's specific was like
jacob is this person it's
unnegotiable okay required i wasn't
gonna i was like all right no
well it works for me i i think you you
you fit that role we won't tease it
anymore maybe we'll happen yeah yeah but
as uh you know to because i keep doing
this so john
you're in kansas city
i am in kansas city the final stop what
up how is it how are you liking it
what's the plan there how long you gonna
be there for can we come visit did i
tell you guys the the what the update on
my travels did i mention that i never
remember what i say when i don't think
okay so
all the air being being around the world
was fun
but one thing i discovered
was that i
like stability
and that stability is good for my mental
health
uh over the past four or five i guess
five months now at this point
um my mental health has not been the
best okay uh constantly changing
locations
and each airbnb you know isn't perfect
so having to deal with the different
quirks of each airbnb
um never really knowing where the [ __ ] i
am
um that all had a negative effect on me
uh
and it took me a while to realize it
because it it was slow building yeah um
and so i decided i gotta not do that
uh indefinitely well you could just
travel for two weeks and then come back
to a home base exactly yeah so uh
kansas city is now my home base that's
why i've come here cool i actually just
signed a lease on an apartment yesterday
um i yeah they locked
out this one it's an awesome apartment
that was like
rent they it was a you know the classic
they buy a big house and then convert it
into like apartments yeah but they're
just they're both designers or something
and so they put like a lot of thought
and care into the reno
that's it's renovation it's short for
renovation nice
didn't uh not hip to your missouri lingo
and so it's got just like
it's not uh like a flip and slip
job or whatever
it's a it's nice looking okay yep and
it's got a mini minis
when i'm in la this weekend
can we go put our fingers in a minimize
we can go to one aquarium if you want
yeah go to long beach this is a there's
some uh yeah i got time anemones there
kansas city has a red light district is
that why your eyes got wide a few
seconds ago
yeah
i mean everywhere has massage parlors
but that's not the same
well yeah we can we'll come visit you at
some point but congrats on making a home
base uh how long have you been that
phone now like a week
no i've been here
i got here on
[ __ ]
on the 8th oh wow that's way longer than
i thought so it's two weeks yeah hot
minute
um yeah i did a game jam uh while i was
here
oh yes how did that go
uh well here's what happened so i
announced that i was doing the game jam
by the way i did a game jam in amsterdam
and it went great three days
it was fun i mean a little hamster game
yeah video game somebody somebody speed
ran it and got like a five second time
because they five seconds let's glitch
through the wall wow
um
so this one it was a 10 day started last
wednesday and ended just yesterday
um
so i announced it that i was doing it
uh i streamed the day that it started
where we did all the planning everything
we were gonna do
um
and then
i don't know what happened
but
i i
started smoking a bunch of weed and then
i built three gundams and i beat metroid
prime four times nice over the past 10
days nice and i did not really make any
progress on the game jam
[Laughter]
so
that did not happen
what type of weed got you to do all of
that had that pro productivity
uh so you know that jack herrera man i
also don't know that that counts as
productivity like yeah you did stuff but
playing video games is pretty normal for
people who are high right oh really
building three gundams really by the way
while we're on the road
jacob can you show us the gundam
unleashed can you just
show us he's in the frame this shirt's
not on it's very embarrassing he's naked
the perspective on that was weird i was
like is that huge four foot tall that is
huge very tall look at that wow look at
him he got him posted everything yeah
he's sassy
he's cool
i don't know what it's called
yeah look at that booty
i made this one that was great
i don't know how long it has
but i lost the connector for the foot so
i made it look like he's battle
like
i'm building zaku right now this okay so
the same thing that's the same saku oh
look at that c5 yeah this one took me
this one only took me like three or four
hours i'll probably finish the big guy
this week what do you think of this
i do think that's super cool what is
that a vape
now dude it's the doom card
that is cool
does it work
[Laughter]
is there like a breeze or something
because the your bedroom door behind you
it keeps moving yeah looks like there
might be somebody
just like it's only been a few times
it's just a shadow i think it's just
shadow but it's moved like a little bit
yeah it looked like long black hair
okay you guys are over selling
did you see it
did you see it
um yeah well we'll have a day at some
point while we build gundams i swear
it's not going to be anything
this weekend
secret
you will be in town this weekend i look
forward to it maybe we do sunday brunch
wait are you are you really here yeah
yeah i'm here i'm here friday saturday
well okay the event has already happened
by the time this published the um
what are you here for that brunch that
we had on sunday yesterday was great so
good what a good brunch we had and the
gundams we built
oh my gosh
so many how many
that sounds like then jacob punched a
horse
okay
yeah well i don't want to talk about
that that's a hard time ladies and
gentlemen ahab ahab uh thank you
everybody for watching another episode
of idiots and abroad uh we published the
first friday of every month so the next
one will be on the sixth i thought it
was the first monday it is i said the
wrong thing sorry the first monday of
every month because this is up on the
first it'll be up on the sixth but
monday is the first yeah so this one
goes up on the first you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] the next one will be up on the
sixth
okay i understand now this is the first
episode when we record it
we'll be
publishing on december 6th
but you should have said that because it
sounded like you were saying oh this is
coming out november 1st and the next
episode will be november 6th you were
missing the word december
it's because it's it's relevant the
audience understands
we just the audience you see
guys say your calendars for december 6th
i said it'll be up on the sixth of next
month they're all like oh it's november
now when this is out okay
oh right she's doing this it's october
now yeah but today
what you're saying
exactly [ __ ]
me okay we got i think i wait one more
time ahab
uh but thank you all for watching uh
jacob what are you up to where can
people find you
people find me on a good old fun house
on lots of stuff there and on twitch
twitch.tv.jacobful i'll be streaming
some probably streaming some halo with
john like about every week these days oh
yeah yeah getting back to it two days
from ulysses podcast every tuesday night
nice
that would be one day but like one day
yeah
where can you find you what are you up
to
nothing tight
all right
john
where can we find you what are you up to
pizza party dot com
pizza posse
dot com
maybe gonna have a fall collection
coming out i just
had that idea just now
and it's gonna happen there gonna be a
scarf
they do have scarves
happy holidays the suppliers i think
who knows maybe it'll happen maybe it
won't we'll see you guys next month
yeah
bye everyone farewell